Musique dynamique
-Connaissez-vous
leur point commun ?
Toutes et tous ont été
des politiques, évidemment,
mais dans leur jeunesse,
toutes et tous ont été scouts.
Cris d'enfants
Avec ces camps en pleine nature,
sa méthode éducative
basée sur le jeu et l'autonomie,
le scoutisme développerait
une certaine appétence
pour l'engagement
et les carrières politiques.
Aujourd'hui encore,
des élus le revendiquent
comme origine
de leur action publique.
-Les éclaireurs
étaient une belle école,
une belle deuxième famille,
pour me confronter et me préparer
à un engagement de vie.
C'est évident.
-Et d'autres racontent
comment ils ont acquis
leurs compétences politiques
chez les scouts.
-Savoir faire travailler
une équipe ensemble,
savoir l'embarquer
dans une même direction,
je l'ai appris là.
-Je ne dis pas
qu'une fois qu'on a été scout,
qu'on y arrive partout
et qu'on est destinés,
de façon irrésistible,
à exercer
des responsabilités de commandement,
mais c'est une très bonne école.
-Le scoutisme
est le plus grand mouvement
de jeunesse en France.
Majoritairement catholique,
le gros de ces bataillons
se retrouve
chez les Scouts et Guides de France,
puis viennent les Scouts d'Europe
et les Unitaires,
moins nombreux, les Eclaireurs laïcs
et les Scouts protestants,
et enfin, les Scouts israélites
et musulmans.
A chacun son scoutisme,
et pourtant un point commun
reconnu par les chercheurs
en sciences sociales.
-Le scoutisme est un espace
d'expérimentation
et d'apprentissage du politique.
Il y a une forme
d'auto-organisation du scoutisme
qui prépare, finalement,
à la discussion collective,
à la prise de décisions
et de responsabilités.
Acclamations
-Comment
et pourquoi ce mouvement,
créé il y a un siècle
par Baden-Powell pour occuper
la jeunesse pauvre
des faubourgs de Londres,
est devenu une pépinière
de responsables politiques ?
...
Musique douce
Jeune, femme, écologiste,
sa victoire
à la mairie de Poitiers
il y a deux ans
a été une énorme surprise.
A 30 ans,
Léonore Moncond'huy a évincé
le maire sortant de 72 ans,
mettant fin à 43 ans
de gestion socialiste.
...
-Vous pensez être un symbole ?
-C'est une dimension
dont j'ai pris conscience
après mon élection,
où des petites filles m'ont dit :
"C'est vous, la maire ? Vous êtes
une femme ! Vous êtes jeune !"
Il y a une espèce de...
J'ai compris
que pour beaucoup d'entre elles,
mon élection voulait dire :
"C'est possible pour moi aussi."
-Mais en ce début octobre,
la tâche s'annonce compliquée.
Le préfet exige qu'elle retire
une subvention à une association
qui propose des ateliers
de désobéissance civile,
au nom de la loi
dite "séparatisme",
qui prévoit que toute association
remplisse un contrat
d'engagement républicain.
Pour les médias locaux,
c'est un peu le sujet polémique
du moment.
Propos indistincts
-Je ne partage pas l'interprétation
du préfet sur la loi.
Mon opinion n'a pas changé
depuis ma première réponse apportée.
-Pour la conforter
dans son bras de fer avec le préfet,
le soir même,
Léonore Moncond'huy va demander
au conseil municipal un vote
pour le maintien
de la subvention.
-Bonjour.
-La manoeuvre est risquée,
mais la maire
va se montrer persuasive.
Musique classique
-Considérons-nous
qu'il est interdit de poser
la question de la désobéissance
civile dans l'espace public ? Non.
Toutes et tous, nous saluons
Gisèle Halimi et Martin Luther King
dans nos livres d'histoire,
et ce faisant,
nous rendons hommage
à des femmes et à des hommes
dont les combats
n'auraient jamais été gagnés
sans une forme
de désobéissance civile.
Je vous propose ainsi, ce soir,
que nous votions
le maintien à la subvention
d'Alternatiba.
Y a-t-il...
Des prises de parole ?
-Je maintiens mon désaccord
avec vous
et avec vos propos
que je relirai attentivement,
mais qui sont chargés d'ambiguïté.
-Qui est pour
le maintien
de la subvention
à l'association Alternatiba ?
C'est bon, Claire ?
C'est bon ?
Applaudissements
-La jeune élue
paraît sûre d'elle.
Cet aplomb, elle le tient
de ses 15 années passées
chez les Eclaireurs
Unionistes de France,
les scouts protestants,
qui l'auraient guidée naturellement
vers la politique.
-La pédagogie scoute aide à prendre
des responsabilités très jeune
et donne confiance
dans le fait d'oser.
Oui, ça m'a donné confiance
en le fait de pouvoir
être capable d'apprendre
ce que je ne connaissais pas,
les missions nouvelles,
les projets d'envergure.
Je ne suis pas experte, a priori,
mais j'ai confiance en le fait
de pouvoir progresser avec l'équipe,
au fil du mandat.
-Dans son bureau,
une photo révélatrice :
celle du soir
de sa victoire.
Une aventure collective,
car Léonore Moncond'huy
n'a pas été désignée par un parti
mais par une assemblée citoyenne
très impliquée
dans sa campagne.
Musique douce
-Je suis au centre,
mais il y a vraiment
tout un collectif de personnes.
Le collectif,
c'est ma manière de fonctionner
depuis que j'ai l'âge
de m'engager.
Chez les scouts, en particulier,
tout est structuré
autour de la vie d'équipe,
que ce soit la vie quotidienne,
les tâches quotidiennes,
on dort en groupe,
on mange en équipe,
on vit des aventures
en équipe.
Moi, ça m'a donné, vraiment,
un goût, une appétence
pour le travail collectif
et ces savoir-faire.
-Le collectif,
la marque de fabrique
du scoutisme.
-Rassemblement !
-Nous sommes au premier camp
de la saison
du groupe des Scouts
et Guides de France,
le plus important
des mouvements.
Ici, celui de Viroflay,
en région parisienne.
Presque 200 scouts
et, comme toujours,
les petits sont encadrés
par les grands.
Foulards et chemises
sont de rigueur.
Musique tonique
-OK, allez,
on prend les sardines.
Marius, 20 ans,
est étudiant
en école d'ingénieur.
...
Lui a commencé le scoutisme
à l'âge de huit ans.
Cette année, il a voulu donner
de son temps pour le mouvement.
-J'ai décidé de devenir chef,
un peu,
pour rendre
tout ce que l'on m'a donné
pendant ces 12 années
de scoutisme.
On est bénévoles.
J'ai adoré mes chefs
et j'aimerais rendre
tout ce que l'on m'a donné.
-Le maître mot : l'entraide.
-Il faut ouvrir plus.
-J'ai ouvert.
-Quand Marius ne sait plus
comment monter une tente,
il y a forcément quelqu'un
pour lui montrer.
-C'est un peu galère,
mais on a réussi.
-Heureusement
que le chef expérimenté...
-Il fallait juste...
-C'est lui qui a de l'expérience.
-Avant d'être chef,
les enfants sont classés
par tranche d'âge,
chacun avec sa couleur d'uniforme
et son nom.
-Est-ce qu'on a des Farfadets ?
Les enfants crient.
-En vert clair, les Farfadets,
les 6-8 ans.
-Des Jeannettes ?
...
-Les Jeannettes,
les filles de 8 à 12 ans.
-Est-ce qu'on a
des Louveteaux ?
-A leur âge, les garçons s'appellent
les Louveteaux.
-Est-ce qu'on a des Scouts ?
-Les Scouts, ce sont les garçons
de 12 à 14 ans,
tandis que les filles
s'appellent les Guides.
-Alors, les Guides ?
...
-Puis viennent les Pionniers
et les caravelles.
-Est-ce qu'on a des pions
et des caras ?
Musique entraînante
...
Est-ce qu'il reste des compas ?
-Enfin, les compas,
comprenez les Compagnons,
de 17 à 21 ans.
Pour symboliser
le changement de tranche d'âge,
il y a des rites de passage,
ce qu'on appelle les montées.
Une mini-cérémonie organisée
en public, un peu
comme dans le monde politique.
Ils chantent.
-Le fait d'être porté
par tout le monde,
ça sent un peu l'esprit
de communauté.
Il y a cet aspect de :
"Je rentre dans les scouts,
"je monte d'un cran,
je suis accompagné."
C'est ça qui est,
je trouve, sympa,
c'est que tout le monde
assiste à la montée.
C'est...
Ca fait du bien.
C'est sympa.
-Etre porté cultive
la confiance en l'autre.
-Bravo !
-Des souvenirs de scouts,
Léonore Moncond'huy
en a 1000 à raconter.
-J'ai mon foulard
qui est toujours le même.
C'est celui de Poitiers.
J'ai ce modèle-là
depuis l'âge de 11 ans.
Je vous ai amené mon opinel,
mon sifflet,
qui sont les outils indispensables
du responsable scout.
-Pour elle, le scoutisme est aussi
une école d'apprentissage
à la politique,
surtout lors d'un grand classique :
le voyage à l'étranger
pris en charge
par les jeunes eux-mêmes,
à partir de 17 ans.
-On avait monté un projet
au Guatemala.
On était allés passer un mois
dans une communauté autogérée
parce qu'on voulait comprendre
comment ils vivaient
en alternative
par rapport à une société
plus conventionnelle.
Ils avaient une forme démocratique
très innovante.
On était allés vivre avec eux
pendant un mois.
C'était une expérience
extrêmement formatrice,
parce qu'on avait passé
deux ans
à préparer notre projet
ensemble,
à trouver nous-mêmes
les fonds nécessaires
pour financer notre voyage,
trouver les partenaires,
apprendre à parler espagnol.
C'est hors norme par rapport
à ce que la société
propose aujourd'hui,
où on a tendance à aller
vers une surprotection
des enfants.
Les scouts, ça apprend aussi
l'autonomie et l'engagement.
-Retour au camp
des Scouts et Guides de France
de Viroflay.
Après le montage
des tentes...
-Vous avez fait
des groupes de deux ?
-...pas facile pour Marius
d'imposer son autorité
à des Louveteaux
pas forcément disciplinés.
-Les gars, on fait un test
pour ce soir.
Si à trois,
c'est trop turbulent...
-Et c'est cela aussi,
l'apport du scoutisme
pour les encadrants.
-OK ! OK !
Non, on a dit par sizaine,
les filles, c'est bon ?
Go ! Allez, allez !
Ca apprend plutôt à...
pas diriger
parce que le terme est un peu fort,
ça fait un peu autoritaire,
mais ça apprend un peu à...
à conduire un groupe,
à organiser,
à un peu guider.
-Savoir mener un collectif
et son pendant,
savoir faire bloc :
des qualités essentielles
en politique.
Ancien président
du groupe LREM
à l'Assemblée nationale,
Gilles Le Gendre
en sait quelque chose.
-J'ai commencé à être scout à 8 ans.
A l'époque,
on disait Louveteau.
A ce moment-là, on n'a pas forcément
le goût de la vie collective.
On a plutôt le goût
de la castagne,
de la rivalité,
de la concurrence.
Précisément, le scoutisme permet
de dompter ce sentiment,
d'introduire le sentiment
de discipline.
En politique,
ça n'est pas superflu.
-Et il en a gardé des réflexes
de chef scout
auprès de ses collaborateurs
parlementaires.
-Ton discours est bien,
mais je pense qu'il faut
qu'on le cheville différemment.
Tes éléments de langage,
c'est le droit de proposer
vs le droit d'abroger, etc.
-Il ne m'en a jamais parlé,
mais étrangement,
ça me surprend pas non plus
qu'il ait été scout.
-En tant que Louveteau,
Gilles Le Gendre
a vécu de très près
une révolution
dans le monde du scoutisme :
la scission chez les scouts
catholiques français.
-Mon troisième frère,
Olivier, a fondé
l'une des grandes associations
de scoutisme aujourd'hui.
Tout ça est intervenu
trois ans après mai 68.
Et trois ans après mai 68,
le scoutisme français,
les Scouts de France,
ça s'appelait,
qui était le mouvement
ultra dominant,
a engagé
une sorte de mutation,
qui était peut-être bien
ou peut-être pas bien,
mais qui aboutissait tout de même
à remettre en cause
pas mal des fondamentaux
du scoutisme.
Et les Scouts Unitaires
de France
ont souhaité rester
dans la ligne originelle,
et c'est pour ça aussi
que cette association
a été créée.
-En 1971,
le scoutisme vit
un véritable schisme
à la fois politique
et pédagogique.
-POURQUOI REGARDER
EN ARRIERE
-La société ayant évolué,
il fallait
que le mouvement évolue
et colle à la réalité.
C'est la raison
pour laquelle
nous nous attardons plus
sur cette proportion
d'ouverture vers le monde.
-C'est l'époque
des prêtres ouvriers,
c'est l'aumônier
qui va prendre la guitare
et chanter des chansons populaires.
Toute cette dimension
d'actualisation,
cette volonté de modernisation,
en tout cas en partie,
des méthodes et des pratiques
dans le scoutisme catholique
entraîne en réaction un refus
d'une partie des membres,
des cadres, des parents,
des enfants,
qui décident alors de créer
leur propre association.
Il y a quelque chose de particulier
dans le scoutisme.
On a l'impression que c'est un monde
à part, ringard, dans les bois.
Or le scoutisme
est complètement perméable
à l'ensemble de la société.
-Les Scouts Unitaires, eux,
sont plus traditionnels.
Pourtant,
Gilles Le Gendre
se souvient
d'un mouvement
pas si homogène.
-Ce qui est certain,
c'est que nous cultivions
l'amour de la patrie,
ça, c'est absolument clair,
une passion, un intérêt
pour la chose publique.
C'est vrai que tous les matins,
en camps,
on se retrouvait tous
pour monter les couleurs.
Mais j'avais, comme copains scouts
avec moi,
qui portaient l'uniforme scout
avec moi, des copains qui,
le samedi, militaient avec la Ligue
communiste révolutionnaire
de l'époque, la LCR, et allaient
donner le coup de poing
contre ce qu'on appelait les "fafs"
du GUD,
des syndicats étudiants
de droite ou d'extrême-droite,
et tout le monde se retrouvait
à monter des couleurs ensemble.
-A la fin de ses années
de scoutisme,
Gilles Le Gendre s'engage
pour la campagne présidentielle
de Valéry Giscard d'Estaing
et son projet
d'une société
plus émancipée.
Et aujourd'hui, de quel bord
politique sont les coûts ?
Dans les camps,
lors des week-ends,
on cultive les discussions
autour de sujets de société.
Mais est-ce que cela débouche
sur un engagement partisan ?
-Je pense qu'il y a pas du tout
de droite ou de gauche,
au scoutisme,
parce que c'est un mouvement
qui est politique
dans ses engagements
mais qui est apolitique
dans ses...
Qui ne prend pas de parti, en fait.
Donc on peut retrouver
beaucoup d'opinions différentes,
mais pour autant,
on se retrouve
sur des valeurs communes.
-Il y a beaucoup
d'enfants de parents de droite
alors que ça promeut
des valeurs de gauche, je trouve.
Non mais si, parce que...
Bon, voilà, l'esprit, le collectif,
la nature, tout ça,
ça m'a l'air d'être plus de gauche,
mais c'est un avis personnel.
-Ce qui est lancé
comme une boutade
n'est pas forcément loin
de la réalité.
Maxime Vanhoenacker
pilote une énorme enquête
intitulée "Scouto".
Il a interrogé
plus de 5200 scouts majeurs
ou anciens scouts.
Il leur a entre autres
demandé pour qui
ils avaient voté aux dernières
élections présidentielles.
Et les résultats sont surprenants.
-Quand on regarde
les résultats du premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle,
c'est le candidat Mélenchon
qui arrive légèrement en tête
devant le candidat Macron,
le candidat Zemmour
et puis le candidat Jadot.
Donc on a quelque chose
qui est très différent
du reste de la population.
On a beau avoir
une population qui se dit
plutôt à droite, on a quand même
un vote qui est plutôt...
à gauche, voire extrême gauche,
ou au centre.
-Dans l'enquête,
plus de 92 %
des scouts
ou anciens scouts
disent s'être déplacés pour voter,
c'est plus de 20 points de plus
que la moyenne nationale.
D'une façon générale,
le scoutisme
favorise l'engagement
pour les autres.
-JOYEUX ANNIVERSAIRE
-Flore, 22 ans,
fait des études
dans une prestigieuse école
de commerce à Lyon,
mais c'est dans l'économie
sociale et solidaire
qu'elle veut travailler,
dans la lignée de son engagement
chez les scouts.
-Tout le long du parcours scout,
on nous apprend à aider les autres,
à vivre en communauté,
donc forcément, ça crée un penchant
pour tout ce qui est solidaire,
tout ce qui est
social et en commun.
L'an dernier, j'ai été bénévole
dans la prison de Lyon-Corbas.
Pendant toute l'année,
j'ai fait des cours
de soutien scolaire
aux femmes détenues.
-Etre au service des autres,
faire la BA, la bonne action,
c'est dans l'ADN
du scoutisme depuis Baden-Powell.
Et pour certains, ces préceptes
se sont mués
en actions politiques.
Brouhaha
Un vendredi de novembre,
près de Lyon.
-Il y a des élections ?
-Non, je tiens ma permanence
sur le marché tous les mois.
-Vous êtes député de Villeurbanne ?
-Oui, d'ici.
-Quelle tendance ?
-Je suis Nouvelle Union Populaire.
-Gabriel Amard, député du Rhône,
est entré
aux Eclaireurs de France,
le mouvement laïque du scoutisme,
à l'âge de 7 ans.
Etre immergé dans la nature
lui a appris
le sens du concret.
-L'école, bien sûr,
nous apprenait beaucoup de choses,
mais le fait d'être toujours
tourné vers l'action et le concret,
ce sont les Eclaireuses
et les Eclaireurs de France,
très évidemment.
Pas de bla-bla, il faut faire.
Il y a un problème, une souffrance,
une douleur, une difficulté,
une pollution, un béal
qui est esquinté quelque part,
allez, on y va, on va aider,
on va restaurer,
on va se rendre utile.
Il faut pas faire des discours
sur l'altruisme et l'entraide,
il faut faire.
Ca, c'est le scoutisme, bien sûr.
-Le député travaille
sur une proposition de loi
sur l'accès à l'eau
pour tous.
Alors pour voir concrètement
les initiatives innovantes
dans le domaine, il retrouve
le maire de Villeurbanne.
-Bon, salut.
-Cédric Van Styvendael
a mis en place un lieu d'accueil
pour les plus précaires.
...
-Bonjour, Gabriel Amard.
-Je suis le président du foyer.
-Ici, on aide les sans-abri,
des gens qui vivent
dans leur voiture ou des réfugiés,
en leur offrant un café
et l'écoute
d'une assistante sociale.
-Ca fait une centaine
de nouvelles familles sur 2021,
qui n'est pas terminée.
C'est en augmentation
ces dernières années.
-Mais ici, surtout,
on leur donne accès
à l'hygiène.
Une buanderie
avec des machines à laver
est disponible gratuitement.
-Là, c'est un lieu
où il y a des machines
pour laver des vêtements.
-On peut venir plusieurs fois
par semaine ?
-Par rendez-vous.
On prend rendez-vous et on vient.
-D'accord.
-Dans un ancien
vestiaire de sport,
des douches sont également
accessibles à tous.
-Oui, oui, j'y vais.
-Quand on arrive,
on s'inscrit.
On nous offre
les serviettes,
du shampoing,
du savon...
Tout le nécessaire.
-L'accès à l'eau,
il y a une filiation directement
avec les Scouts ?
-Quand on faisait
des collectes alimentaires
ou qu'on vendait la vignette
pour la jeunesse en plein air,
je crois
qu'on nous a très vite appris
qu'il y avait
des difficultés
et que dans un pays
aussi riche que le nôtre,
il fallait faire en sorte
qu'il y ait du partage.
Donc, oui. Moi, ça a fait
que je ne pouvais pas me retrouver
ailleurs
que du côté du peuple
et de ses colères,
et de ses souffrances,
en ayant fait 13 ans aux Eclaireuses
et Eclaireurs de France.
-Mais l'originalité du projet
tient aussi à sa jeunesse.
Ce foyer a été proposé
par un jury citoyen
et le politique a suivi.
-Sur...
La démarche citoyenne
à l'origine de ce projet,
c'est le Scout
Cédric Van Styvendael,
qui doit nous en parler.
-Ca m'a appris à transformer
ce que je savais.
Ca m'a aussi appris
que seul, on ne fait rien, en fait.
Si on n'est pas capable
d'embarquer,
et c'est ce qu'on a fait
sur ce jury citoyen.
Ce n'est pas simplement
l'intelligence citoyenne,
c'est aussi...
Le politique,
s'il ne crée pas de l'appétence
et de la légitimité en se disant :
"Je ne décide pas tout seul,
mais je confronte..."
C'est finalement
le boulot d'un député.
On a l'impression
que c'est compliqué,
mais il faut juste que la loi
soit en phase
avec ce qu'attendent les Français,
avec le réel.
Moi, je crois
que ça m'a appris cela,
cet engagement.
-Souvent,
on se retrouve
en anciens Scouts.
"Moi aussi, j'y étais."
On découvre ça
toujours après.
-Finalement,
il n'y a pas de hasard.
-Par contre,
il n'y a pas de réseau.
C'est pas
comme les grandes écoles.
Mais vous avez raison de dire :
"On se reconnaît."
En fait,
on se reconnaît.
Il y a des réflexes.
Ca donne envie de faire
des choses avec les autres.
On va pas vous faire toutes
les citations, mais il y en a une :
"Laissez ce monde
un peu meilleur
"que vous ne l'avez trouvé
en arrivant."
Ca semble modeste pour un homme
politique comme objectif.
Moi, ça me va, déjà.
Laisser ce monde
meilleur en partant
qu'en arrivant.
C'est déjà un bel objectif.
-Ca m'amène, par exemple,
à passer
du scoutisme
à l'antiracisme.
Je rappelle souvent que c'est
la réforme de la nationalité
et la remise en cause
du droit du sol par Pasqua
qui m'amènent à passer
des "ecclés" à l'engagement...
-A SOS Racisme ?
-Non, moi,
aux jeunesses socialistes.
-Ah, oui, j'avais oublié.
-J'y suis entré, dans la réforme
du code de la nationalité
et la remise en cause
du droit du sol.
-Et nos scouts d'aujourd'hui
seront-ils les politiques
de demain ?
Musique entraînante
Parmi nos rencontres,
il y a Luc, déjà engagé
dans le syndicat étudiant Unef,
à l'université Paris Dauphine.
Il se dit :
"Pourquoi pas ?"
-Je vis à Versailles.
Peut-être des élections municipales
avec le Parti Socialiste ou EELV,
je suis pas sûr qu'il
y ait grand monde.
S'il y a besoin d'aide...
Conseiller municipal,
pas plus.
-Et puis,
il y a Théobalt,
étudiant
à Sciences Po Paris.
-Vous vous voyez où
dans 10 ans ?
-Je ne sais pas.
Pas vraiment.
Je me vois
dans une entreprise.
Probablement dans la direction
d'une entreprise...
en essayant d'avoir
le plus d'impact possible
pour qu'elle devienne
plus responsable.
-Et pas de la politique ?
-Je ne sais pas.
Peut-être.
En tout cas,
c'est pas dans mes projets.
-Les envies des plus jeunes
restent assez conformes
aux aspirations
de leur âge.
-Tu sais ce que tu veux faire
dans la vie ?
-Pompier.
-Vétérinaire, peut-être,
mais ça a l'air
un peu difficile quand même.
Mais bon...
-Testeur
de sensations fortes.
-J'aimerais être policière.
-Peut-être chanteuse aussi.
-Sur les traces
de la Première ministre,
Nathanael se voit...
-Polytechnicien.
-Tu veux faire polytechnicien ?
-Oui.
-Dis donc, c'est ambitieux.
-Oui, mais je pense
que je suis déjà bien parti.
-Ah bon, pourquoi ?
-Pour Polytechnique, il faut
savoir beaucoup de choses.
Comme je suis 1er de la classe,
je pense...
je pense que c'est
peut-être bon pour ça.
*-Les chorégraphes sont attendus !
-Pas sûr que ces jeunes scouts
fassent un jour de la politique,
mais ils seront sans doute
des adultes plus engagés
dans des associations
ou des syndicats,
plus solidaires,
pour une citoyenneté active.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA